Er hat es schon wieder getan.
Alain Robert - bekanntgeworden als der "französische
Spiderman" - ist am Mittwoch an der Fassade
des vierthöchsten Hochhauses in der französischen
Hauptstadt Paris hochgeklettert.
Für den Für den 187-Meter hohen Tour Total
brauchte der Extremkletterer etwas mehr als eine Stunde.
Zahlreiche Schaulustige sahen ihm staunend
zu.
In der Vergangenheit hatte Robert dieses Gebäude
bereits zweimal bezwungen.
Daneben aber noch mehr als 150 beeindruckende
Hochhäuser in der ganzen Welt.
Er könne das Klettern einfach nicht lassen,
sagt Robert:
"Für mich ist das Klettern eine Leidenschaft,
es ist eine Art zu Leben.
Ich habe mit dem Klettern im Alter von 11
Jahren angefangen.
Ich werde bald 56 Jahre und daran, irgendwann
mit dem Klettern aufzuhören, denke ich überhaupt nicht.
Es sei denn, ich bekomme eine sehr ernste
Krankheit, die mich vom davon abhält.
Sonst werde ich weitermachen."
Nicht immer darf er allerdings so, wie er
will.
Er klettert immer ohne Erlaubnis und wurde
deswegen schon mehrfach verhaftet.
Das konnte ihn allerdings noch nicht dazu
bringen, sich von den Hochhäusern fernzuhalten.